we all about ready to crack into it
sweet we will crack into the first
meeting uh right away because it is so
short and get these uh committees
through and then we can get on to um
we've got three meetings here today so
we've got lots of chew through uh so I
won't hold it up too much
uh apologies so we have apologies from
um councilor mcnell and also councilor
Stringer
do we have any other apologies
no uh could I please have a mover for
those do I need to move us yes yeah
could I please have a move it um Neville
and uh seconder uh glennis uh all those
in favor please say aye
and against the motion is carried
committee membership and Council and
governance committee terms of reference
2022 to 2025.
it's not attached here
um but I thought
um is it if all the capsules around the
table receive the the list if they've
read through it they're all okay I will
read through it anyway
um
for the staff and media in the room let
me just find it
oh you got here oh perfect
so assets and infrastructure will
consist of myself Brit Joe John Neville
Paul Robert and Stewart
order and risk will consist of myself
Brit Bronwyn Joe John Paul Richard
Stewart and Michael Chamberlain
Community well-being will consist of
myself Brett bromwan Glynis Keith
Neville Paul Richard and Roberts policy
and planning will consist of myself
Bronwyn glennis Keith Richard Robert and
Stewart
and the district plan subcommittee will
consist of myself glennis Joe John Keith
and Neville
there's a list here if you want to
[Laughter]
yes was that too fast for you
so there's committees two Committees of
eights one Committee of seven which is
policy and planning and one Committee of
nine which is community well-being
did we have any uh mention from the
report writer or the chief executive I
believe it was Rex there's only just
been adjustment so
uh question
for either rexor or
um and the district plan subcommittee
you wish there was also a man of finna
were representative that I think should
be noted as well
sorry I believe that's on the back side
of that page so yes I missed that yeah
there's just two questions if I made to
the chief executive
um
and and the first relates to does a
counselor who's not a member of the
committee have speaking rights at that
committee and if the answer is no would
a resolution of council today be
sufficient to provide for councilors who
are not members of the committee to
speak at that committee
uh thank you through your worship
without consulting standing orders which
I actually left at my desk uh normally
taken with me to Council meetings I
thought this was going to be a short one
uh customer practice has normally been
that counselors who are not on
committees have freedom to speak to
items they just can't vote
and and secondly there will be some
delegations that go with the Committees
particularly in relation to liquor
licensing and some of the um other
committees I guess have got delegations
will that be the subject of a separate
report
three years us abuse that's correct
um in either the Flesh on the bones of
your life of committee operations and
delegations will be decided to a simple
report we just try to get the terms of
reference of which is the parameters of
which you operate whether you've got
power to recommend or act and the
membership finalized today
were there any further uh Christians
Commons concerns from councilors on this
matter
I just wanted to check with councilor
hoval there was an argument made at the
last meeting uh around quarterly or as
required I know there was a motion uh to
confirm quarterly and one being
bi-monthly did you have any concerns
with that being written to the terms of
reference or